[Music]
life isn't always as peaceful as it
seems
there might not be any obvious signs of
war
[Music]
but the very nature of warfare is
changing
instead of tanks and troops
[Music]
think hacks and hashtags
[Music]
really sewing division and tearing the
fabric of society apart
it happens in a gray zone of harm
under the threshold of war the key point
here is it's insidious
you don't know that it's a threat online
a new front line
it's where our minds meet machines and
where machines influence our minds
it's where physical attacks take place
too we've got to
be successful in treating them because
otherwise there's going to be world war
iii
but what does it mean for the uk's
security
there is this disregard for the human
consequences
this is going to be very very difficult
for us we need to be able to contest in
cyber space and this isn't just a
challenge for soldiers and spies
the gray zone challenges everyone
[Music]
why start an armed conflict if you don't
have to
that's where the gray zone comes in it's
a murky space between
war and peace where states criminals and
terrorists
launch covert attacks to deceive gain
influence
even kill here there are no rules
and literally anything can be and is
used as a weapon
a significant challenge then for the
defense secretary and military chief
two of the most senior officials charged
with defending the uk
you say we aren't in a state of peace
and we're not in a state of war
what are we in contest
we're competed against every day
some people compete within the rules and
some people compete
outside the norms or the rules that
we've all got used to every day
we myself chief of defense staff and
intelligence services see
our adversaries using cyber tools
against us
using disinformation into our society
in in some areas using financial
corruption using organized crime
to divide us to weaken us
or to compete with us what is the risk
if we don't
react and we don't change and we don't
adapt
so on the one hand we might wake up one
day and discover that we are in a police
state
and all of our freedoms have been denied
us that's one end of it
the other end of it is that our
opponents will have found a way to
unravel our democracy from inside and
our freedom our way of life
and all the things that we aspires would
have been undermined and we won't have
noticed it
without a shot being fired that that
successful gray zone warfare from
adversaries
the whole concept of what warfare can be
and therefore what the threat looks like
is changing
try to think of the gray zone as a
global battlefield
the front line is everywhere and no one
is too
unimportant to be a target the weapons
of choice
include deliberately crafted lies spread
online
cyber attacks and coercion
so hostilities are often invisible i
asked a chief of the defense staff in
2014 if we had had
hot wars and the cold war and now we're
in a boiling frog
and he laughed but that terminology is
being used now
sally walker spent 25 years at gchq
she left in 2020 and this is her first
television interview
it means that the temperature is rising
and we are not noticing because this is
happening
around us to us can you just describe in
your words like what is the gray zone
i think most people conceive of the gray
zone as the online environment
and that forgets the human dimension
it's where
our minds meet machines and where
machines influence our minds
that to me describes the grey zone
the killing of journalists jamal
khashoggi by a saudi hit team
allegedly sanctioned by the crown prince
though that's denied
shows the gray zone has many physical
dimensions too
from assassinations and intimidation to
infiltrating a country's energy
or defense sectors the key point here is
it's insidious
you don't know that it's a threat
necessary
lord sedwell was the uk's national
security advisor
until last september if there are
accusations
about corruption are those real or are
those
manufactured is there dirty money that
is flowing into
our economic and political system do we
know
the origins of that and is there a
controlling intelligence behind it that
is seeking to
undermine the confidence between the
citizen
and the state and that's what grey's own
um conflict grey's end hostilities are
about
it's creating new work for britain's
spies
so on the one hand we have a sense of
what you might describe as the
traditional threat which is the
intelligence services which operate in
ways which are
broadly understood in a very kind of
disciplined if ruthless way
this is the first time an mi5 officer
working in counter intelligence
has given an interview tom spoke off
camera
to protect his identity so we're
recreating the meeting
and then you have the evolution of this
threat into another area the gray zone
as you describe it
where this is going to be very very
difficult for us
scarlett works for mi6 countering gray's
own activities
she says there have always been such
hostilities
they're just getting noisier i'd say the
volume has been turned up a bit
and there is this kind of disregard for
the human consequences
for the impact on real people and their
lives
this too a recreation of our meeting
corruption plays a really big part in
the gray zone activity by
our adversaries they seek probably to
undermine the political model that
appears to them to be a threat and that
feels quite zero-sum
let's go after economies societies our
value structures what we stand up for
freedom of speech again to benefit and
enrich a tiny group of people
at the cost of the millions that live in
those countries and at the cost of the
societies that they're attempting to
threaten
[Music]
one of the most powerful gray zone
weapons is
information or disinformation to
influence
minds a hostile state
might spread lies or a distorted version
of the truth
across news channels and social media
sites
to undermine the authorities in another
country
or to amplify divisions within a society
over issues like politics race
even the coronavirus pandemic sally
draws an analogy
with covert 19 to describe the challenge
it's a silent threat
we could be asymptomatic carriers of it
it may infect us but cause no harm
but impact someone else in a very
different way
and we need to respond with collective
behaviors
it's important to remember the use of
fake news as a weapon
is nothing new
german radio stations during the second
world war
to fool the nazis soviet
as well as british and american spies in
the cold war were also
master manipulators of information
the game changer today though is digital
technology and the internet
it's scale volume and
erosion of trust and truth there's no
bin
in the internet we don't get to delete
information that's wrong
and it can contaminate searches and
sources for
years even decades to come so where you
have
bad information poor quality information
disinformation
it has a legacy impact on society
that we haven't yet quantified and we
have no solution to
i accept your nomination for
president of the united states
in 2016 hillary clinton's u.s election
campaign
came under a significant information
attack blamed on russia
there's no evidence to suggest it
changed the outcome
but fake social media posts and hacked
emails
appeared designed to support donald
trump and attack
his democratic rival the kremlin has
denied any interference
what you're seeing are uh are our
adversaries our rivals
exploiting the tools that are meant to
make for a more utopian society so
things like social media
against us fueling conspiracy theories
and really sowing
division and tearing the fabric of
society apart and
you could go so far and describe it as
almost fueling a civil war inside some
of these societies
general sir patrick sanders spoke to me
with the head of gchq
in their first joint interview in
today's world where technology is
prevalent and uh where it affects all of
our lives in our in our private lives
and in our
in our business lives that we need to be
able not only to defend
the digital homeland our our uh defend
the uk
we need to be able to compete with our
adversaries we need to be able to
contest
in cyber space
to complicate things it's not just
hostile foreign states playing tricks
with information
domestic political parties activist
groups
and individuals do it too we will never
give up we will never concede it doesn't
happen
you don't concede when there's depth
[Applause]
donald trump and his supporters refuse
to accept
joe biden won the 2020 election
[Applause]
instead making unsubstantiated
allegations about
widespread voter fraud
some of his followers even stormed the
seat of u.s democracy
the capitol building driven by a bogus
belief
their man had been cheated out of a
second term
[Music]
five people died including a police
officer
evidence of the power of false
information
and the risk of real-world violence when
two sides can no longer agree on facts
it also underlines the challenge of how
to defend a democracy
from an information attack by a hostile
foreign state
while at the same time allowing the
people
in that democracy the right to free
speech which of course
includes the freedom to lie
suspected disinformation from russia is
what flooded the internet three years
ago
as part of one of the most infamous gray
zone attacks on the uk
the attempted assassination of a russian
double agent and his daughter
this was a wholly disproportionate and
outrageous
invasion against the united kingdom it
meant the uk
had to fight back in the gray zone
[Music]
the different coloured pavement a
permanent reminder
of the first chemical weapons attack on
european soil
since the second world war it's where a
bench once stood
that sergey skripal and his daughter
yulia collapsed upon
on the 4th of march 2018
they were rushed to hospital fighting
for their lives
we really at the time thought that the
patients
would probably not survive christine
blanchard was in charge of salisbury
district hospital
at the time i do remember one of one of
my itu consultants saying to me well
you know we've got to we've got to be
successful in treating them
because otherwise there's going to be
world war iii she revealed
there were also concerns about a second
assassination attempt
we were of course worried whether
someone might want to come back and
finish off the job
and we didn't know for sure whether
somebody would try
and and kill them
so we had to be very careful to ensure
security in the intensive care unit
making sure that we restricted visitors
and we knew who visitors were
and so and particularly whilst they were
still
unconscious sergey skripal was a former
colonel
in russia's military intelligence agency
the gru
he's thought to have been turned by mi6
in the 1990s to spy for the uk
but was caught and jailed in russia
before being released
in a cold war-style spy swap
he settled down here at this house in
salisbury
and was enjoying a visit from his
daughter who lived in moscow
when two russian giu officers allegedly
walked up to the front door and sprayed
it with the deadly nerve agent novichok
contained in a perfume bottle it was
only a matter of time
until the scrippers became exposed to
the poison
and while they didn't die the grey's own
message
that you are not safe had still been
sent to
anyone viewed as a traitor by the
kremlin
it came as a complete shock to everybody
in my team
tom's team looks at the russia threat
for mi5
i remember we were we were on a
management away day believe it or not
by the time we were back in tem's house
it became apparent who these individuals
were
and at that point mi5 and partners swung
into action
barely a week after the attack then
prime minister theresa may
publicly accused moscow a claim russia
denies
mr speaker there is no alternative
conclusion
other than that the russian state was
culpable for the attempted murder
of mr skripal and his daughter the
united kingdom will now
expel 23 russian diplomats
who have been identified as undeclared
intelligence officers
britain's allies joined the action in a
show of unity
a key way to push back in the gray zone
so we moved very very quickly to put
together the diplomatic sanctions the
expulsions
in particular of the russian
intelligence capabilities military
intelligence capabilities and others
around europe and the uh and the rest of
the western uh democracies to try and
regain the initiative after an attack of
that kind
the poisonings were combined with what
the uk said
was a disinformation operation by moscow
it took people some time to appreciate
was that we weren't
facing our narrative the truth based on
the evidence in the investigation
versus a single alternative narrative
from
the russians so what they sought to do
was simply confuse
and so they put out dozens of different
uh narratives through lots of different
means social media
their official media uh spokesman
and so on really you know changing their
story
um uh contradicting themselves dr
blanchard
said she even came under pressure with a
warning
she might be reported to the general
medical council
i did get a couple of letters purporting
to come from the russian embassy
they looked very important they were on
um very
impressive headed note paper with double
eagles on
um alleging that we were denying the
scripples their consular rights
that this was a serious breach of their
human rights i could be reported to the
gmc
for and so on um
but i'm sure you can imagine why the
the skripals didn't want to meet anyone
from the russian embassy
unpredictable times prompting
unpredictable responses
and now a rare willingness from
britain's spies
to share their views publicly scarlett
says
an important part of operating in the
gray zone is the gathering evidence and
understanding the threat and
sort of almost being a bit obsessive
about the truth because
when you've got that barrage of
disinformation coming at you really fast
you have to try as best you can to
build your picture of what the threat is
and understand how it's shifting and
stay on that course and be be a bit
courageous
because you might have to come up with a
new idea or create something
different in our case you will always
want to work with allies to come up with
whatever the response we need is
we know that our adversaries don't like
it when we collectivise our response
when we come together and respond
together that tends to not go down that
well with the baddies
scarlett says she expects more attacks
from russia
under president vladimir putin i think
in the
immediate term there are going to be
further manifestations of that
recklessness
and also because of the shoddy
tradecraft it is more obvious to
countries that are finding this stuff on
their soil
with the solsby poisonings the discarded
perfume bottle
thought to have been used in the attack
was found by
a local man who unwittingly gave it to
his girlfriend
dawn sturgis became the first death from
this greyzone operation
if you look at the salisbury attack this
was a holy disproportionate and
outrageous invasion against the united
kingdom
and we can't have anything but disgust
for it
the uk accused two suspected gru
officers of the poisonings
they deny being involved claiming they
were in salisbury as tourists
the then russian ambassador to london
rallied against the investigation
that's the story of the of the british
press and also the government
but unfortunately it's not supported by
the fact they said
officially they are not part of the gru
this is first
and second the british side
could have an opportunity to question
them but they will never ask for that
kate also works for mi5 she investigates
the activities of the gru
including the salisbury suspects this is
another reenactment
a lot of our work against hostile states
focuses on espionage
as you'd expect spies investigating
spies to
put it crudely but then acts like
salisbury happen in the gray zone then
it makes you stop
and realize how worlds apart we are from
the intelligence agencies of hostile
states both
in our professional purpose and goals
but also the tools that we're given to
achieve those
goals this isn't a rogue unit they are
acting as part of the russian state
do the uk's intelligence services
conduct the same kind of malign
activities
that the gru is accused of conducting
no absolutely not
i asked scarlett if she's had to adapt
the way she works to deal with gray zone
threats
you have to really understand the full
range of tools that can be used against
us
and then look at our own defenses and
build those up
and develop our own integrated way of
working
i think what the government has done on
the gru is to seek
to deny them the cover of operating in
the shadows
if you come into our country and use a
chemical weapon here we are going to
make that part of our national discourse
we can do that again against adversaries
that would otherwise
choose to operate in the shadows it is
about
denying them that luxury when you can
mi5 is bolstering protection for other
people
in the uk who might be targeted we know
that the russian state continues to take
an interest in people here
who we deem to be at risk and that's
not a passive interest it's quite an
active interest
tom told me the attack here in salisbury
accelerated changes that were already
underway
across the intelligence community to
deal with the russia threat
this includes with mi5 mi6 and gchq
pulling their resources into a single
russia mission
in much the same way as they work
together to counter the threat from
terrorism
he said moscow is keen to rebuild its
team of
intelligence officers at the embassy
have they tried to
and have you been able to stop them i
would say that
it would be a logical assumption that
having lost 23 intelligence officers
the russian government would want to try
and replace them in
some way we work really hard on
preventing them from doing that
have we been entirely successful time
will tell
could mi5 stop another salisbury style
attack
i think we have entered the same realm
that we are in with our
counter-terrorism colleagues which is
that we do absolutely everything we can
to stop any events from taking place in
the uk which are damaging
the uk population or property but there
are no
absolute guarantees i cannot say for
certain
that we are safe no one can
salisbury a very real example of the
unpredictability of the gray zone
and while stopping assassinations is
clearly a job for mi5
spy agencies and the military alone
can't possibly hope to defend the uk and
its democracy
from the full range of subversive
threats
instead like climate change or
coronavirus
every single person has a part to play
in protecting themselves in the gray
zone
from being alert to the possibility of
hostile activity you just can't see
to checking the provenance of the
information you read
if we don't then as a former general
once told me
enjoy the gathering storm because bad
news is coming